bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo 45 minutes pour faire
le tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec catherine bernard
baudoux médias et dans l'actualité cette
semaine certains appellent cela une
mauvaise passe d'autres y verront un
tournant du quinquennat la sphère
leonarda en tout cas n'en finit pas
d'empoisonner la vie du gouvernement au
coeur de ce débat
l'immigration manuel valls veut une
réforme du droit d'asile
l'ump s'en prend au droit du sol
l'actualité parlementaire c'est aussi la
mise à contribution des revenus de
l'épargné pour financer la protection
sociale pap est les assurances vie
seront tous taxés à 15 5% les députés
ont voté l'article de loi sous les huées
de la droite qui dénoncent une mesure
inconstitutionnelle
cette semaine de plus de l'hebdo vous
fera découvrir les premières images du
film cinquième pouvoir c'est l'histoire
de la naissance de ce site internet
wikileaks et de son fondateur julian
assange
ou comment les lanceurs d'alert ont
changé le monde en dévoilant les grands
secrets d'état est notre invité cette
semaine marielle de sarnez bonjour
bonjour à merci d'être avec nous députée
européene vice présidente du modem et
celle de chef de file du modem pour les
municipales à à paris une question vous
habitez dans le 14e depuis toujours et
ce que vous en dites un géant mais
depuis dix ans il avait quand on est
parisienne on a habité dans beaucoup
d'arrondissement moi qui suis parisienne
j'habite ici l'on voyait vraiment une
présenté dans un autre arrondissement
la question des listes est importante la
question de l'endroit où on se présente
est important et ça compte mais ce qui
compte le plus au fond c'est qu'est ce
qu'on a envie de faire de cette ville
quels sont les projets qu'on a envie
d'avancer quelle est la gouvernance que
nous voulons pour cette ville je porte
l'idée d'un renouvellement nécessaire
on doit renouveler la manière dont les
choses se font et se gouverne à paris on
a une gouvernance qui est trop partisane
je veux du renouvellement le
renouvellement ça n'est pas remplacé
simplement une équipe par une autre
c'est changer profondément la manière
dont on gouverne je considère que le
maire de paris et l'équipe municipale sa
boîte est une équipe qui est à la
disposition de l'ensemble des parisiens
quelles que soient leurs opinions
politiques 220 si vous deviez choisir
entre élus de paris est
députée européene les 206 gt a priori
j'étais les rotary bien évidemment je
choisirais la mairie de paris
si je suis une élue parmi d'autres je
continuerai à assumer mes
responsabilités d'élu européenne de
paris pour les années qui viennent
alors en attendant marielle de sarnez on
va passer en revue la sq de la semaine
semaine qui commence sur fond de
cacophonie
loin de calmer les esprits
d'intervention du président de la
république sur la sphère leonarda a
suscité des réactions en ordre dispersé
le sort de la collégienne expulsé divise
la majorité
et le premier ministre tente comme il
peut de recadrer les troupes
yoann l'a officiellement bien sûr pas
question une nouvelle fois de parler de
réunion de crise mais après une semaine
passée à critiquer le gouvernement dans
la sphère léonard d'art l'ancien
président de sos racisme malek boutih
donne sa version de l'ordre du jour la
tentation d'un pouvoir politique quand
il en difficulté dans son propre camp
quand les gens posent des questions qui
sont cause que les électeurs de monde
c'est de demander de la discipline
tout le monde en rang d'oignons voilà en
rang d'oignons justement pour cette
séance de recadrage tout l'état major du
ps sur la sellette
harlem désir ce week end il vient lui
même de contenir le chef de l'état en
estimant que la lycéenne devait rentrer
en france avec sa famille un épisode
qu'il voudrait désormais faire oublier
et aujourd'hui je les dis nous sommes
tous soudés derrière la position qui a
exprimé le président de la république
comme je le dis j'ai eu à dire ce que
j'avais à dire quand le président de la
république a pris une position
eh bien nous les soutenons le débat est
clos quelques minutes plus tard même
invitation du premier ministre plus
question d'évoquer l'émotion suscitée
par l'expulsion de la lycéenne
vous êtes bien placé pour le savoir
qu'il faut de temps en temps revenir à
l'essentiel et pas seulement en reste et
comme vous le faites trop souvent sur
l'émotionnel la standing-ovation réservé
à jean marc ayrault dans l'hémicycle
n'avait pas grand chose de spontané
l'ordre de serrer les rangs et de mettre
fin à la cacophonie mettra peut-être un
peu plus de temps à être entendu la
sphère leonarda la méthode de l'homme
c'est le zoom de la semaine est avec
nous sur ce plateau de synthèse pour
commenter cette actualité thomas guénolé
politologue au cevipof c'est le centre
de recherches politiques de sciences po
marielle de sarnez c'est la première
question je m'adresse à vous très
directement la sphère leonarda nouveau
couac ou tournant du quinquennat
c'est plus qu'un couac je pense que
c'est une crise d'autorité au sommet de
l'état il y a une chose très simple à
dire à nos concitoyens c'est qu'il faut
que les lois soient respectées dans un
pays et c'est comme ça que fonctionne et
doit fonctionner l'état de droit il y a
un droit d'asile politique pour ceux qui
sont opprimés dans leur pays qui doit
absolument perdurer mais pour qu'il
perdure il faut mettre fin à l'ensemble
des abus et donc manuel valls a eu
raison dans l'attitude qui était la
sienne qui est simplement un respect de
la légalité et la réforme qu'il veut
conduire solo droit d'asile je la trouve
pas d'accord mais je la proue elle est
très importante il faut que les délais
soient absolument raccourci qu'on peut
pas laisser une famille attendre quatre
ou cinq ans une réponse de l'état hormis
thomas guinn au lait alors est ce que
vous comprenez quelque chose vous à la
méthode de françois hollande
est-ce que son pouvoir ou son autorité
sont affaiblis alors justement pouvoir
aux autorités
l'étymologie est intéressante à cet
égard c'est à dire que la plupart des
gens emploie les termes indistinctement
alors que ça ne veut pas dire la même
chose
le pouvoir c'est la possibilité
d'exercer une contrainte pour forcer
quelqu'un à faire quelque chose françois
hollande de par les institutions a le
pouvoir l'autorité c'est vous n'avez pas
besoin d'utiliser la contrainte ou de la
standing-ovation sur ordre par exemple
qu'on a vu vous n'avez pas besoin de ça
parce que vous avez aujourd'hui on
dirait autorité naturelle ce qui est un
pléonasme l'autorité c'est toujours
naturel ça va toujours de soi sans même
avoir les institutions quelqu'un en
pierre mendès france est une immense
autorités sans avoir nécessairement le
pouvoir voyez la distinction cette
autorité de la françois hollande
visiblement ne l'a pas c'est toute la
différence justement alors l'idée c'est
que finalement on a une ambiance
la gestion du pouvoir actuellement qui
ressemble à un congrès permanent du
parti socialiste c'est très frappant de
voir à quel point finalement les débats
entre les différents courants et pour
résumer entre la gauche
sociale-démocrate et la gauche marxiste
se poursuivent au fil du temps je
partage mon pour 1 cette analyse se la
question de l'autorité non mais c'est
une vraie question et je vous rejoins
quand vous dites c'est votre formule
entre guillemets c'est un congrès
socialiste permanent pour moi un homme
d'état s'il est un homme d'état doit
gouverner pour l'ensemble des français
et pas pour les intérêts de son parti
et bien évidemment on n'est
malheureusement pas on va dire dans
cette tonalité là or la france en aurait
sacrément besoin vous attendre à ce que
ce seul accès début de quinquennat un
peu comme cela après 18 non je pensais
que françois hollande était plutôt on va
dire un social-démocrate éclairé
revendiquer sa formation c'est plutôt
d'être du côté aux côtés de jacques
delors et puis on a aujourd'hui un
président la république qui n'assume pas
cette autorité qui ne porte pas une
vision et qui n'a pas clarifié les choix
fondamentaux idéologiques de la gauche
exactement et qui n'a pas remis à jour
ce logiciel c'est le pays qui en subit
les conséquences et cantonales guénolé
est ce qu'il y aura pour vous un avant
et un après léonard da ce qui aura des
conséquences profondes sur la majorité
et sur l'opinion pas nécessairement
parce qu'elle est on est passé ces
dernières années au temps très court de
l'information et donc a priori sauf
rebondissement dans deux semaines la
sphère leonarda plus personne n'en
parlera pas d'accord il ya un problème
sûr il ya des problèmes de fond qui
s'accumulent mais le grand le grand
enjeu à mon avis en termes de 2,2 quand
vous dites est ce qu'il y aura un avant
et un après à mon avis à un avant et un
après la séquence municipal puis
européenne
je fais une parenthèse là dessus on
parle beaucoup du risque front national
pour les municipales à mon avis il est
beaucoup moins élevé que le risque est
fun au niveau des européennes où là le
fn pourrait en fait si on regarde les
sondages arriver en tête et un certain
nombre de villes peut-être quelques
dizaines en fait pas plus où il ya un
vrai risque électoral fn en revanche
dans les grandes villes et dans les
villes moyennes le risque est fait n'est
nul pourtant on parle beaucoup plus des
municipales que des européennes dans
l'analyse
d'accord avec cette analyse je crois
qu'il y aura un avant et un après parce
que ça a vraiment mis en cause
l'autorité du chef de l'état et c'est un
problème qu'on va retrouver seul moyen
et le long terme et et j'ai une
inquiétude pour vous rejoindre c'est sur
la question des européennes sous les
scores possibles potentiel de ce qui au
fond veulent la fin de l'europe en
france et dans l'ensemble de l'union
européenne qui peut se comprendre parce
que grave crise de confiance mais ça ça
va être l'engagement du combat de ceux
qui pensent et qui savent que l'europe
est notre seul atout pour exister
question très content sur ce thème à
tous les deux comment vous voyez la
suite du quinquennat
qu'est ce que peut faire françois
hollande il ya un vrai problème c'est à
dire que il ya une accumulation de
circonstances défavorables
il faut bien se dire que on entre on en
est à 30 ans de chômage persistant et de
crise économique et sociale persistante
donc on est dans une société de défiance
alors qu'avant on a vous pouvez parler
de ce site et de confiance à l'époque
des trente glorieuses
tous les ingrédients au frente soir oui
mais le problème c'est que comme dans le
même temps il ya une dette publique
accumulée qui réduit les marges de
manoeuvre et oblige à une politique
d'austérité ou à la réputation la dette
on est dans des circonstances où en fait
françois hollande des langues lentement
étrangler au niveau de la marge
manoeuvre politique
en attendant la croissance comme
d'autres attendent et godeau soit il
continue comme ça et et on va continuer
à avoir un délitement un délitement
france une vraie perte de confiance avec
tous les risques qui peuvent arriver
avec soin il réagi et pour moi réagir ça
veut dire changer de politique
ça veut dire assumer clairement une
politique de réformes dans la france a
besoin
alors on continue la semaine d'abord je
vous remercie thomas guénolé d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous avez
écrit ce livre
nicolas sarkozy chronique d'un retour
impossible pour l'interrogation
merci donc nuls et nous on va parler des
centristes si vous lui est bien réel de
sarnez
vous devez être au courant lui dit fête
ses un an
vous ne tiendrez n'est ce pas le mariage
entre lui et le modem mais on a voulu
aller à l'anniversaire de lui des lycées
ccil ci dessous qui a laissé traîner son
micro pour savoir ce qu'il pensait un
petit peu de ce mariage regarder le
mariage n'est pas encore consommée mais
ce soir au calme j'ai remis au président
des jeunes modène dans les
hauts-de-seine est venu en curieux pour
rencontrer ceux qui pourraient bientôt
être les membres de sa future famille
politique
j'attends de voir justement ce qui va se
passer dans le futur contrat de mariage
qu'on nous annonce entre notre mouvement
donc le mouvement démocrate et l'union
des démocrates et des indépendants chose
qui est que je demandé que j'attends
depuis longtemps c'est qu'on soit un
centre on est une union descente
voilà pour les municipales surtout puis
après pour les européennes s'unir pour
les élections du côté des militants udi
aussi l'idée fait son chemin
le modem maintenant c est rentré dans
une posture qui est beaucoup plus
d'opposition et de critiques du
gouvernement actuel donc à partir de là
on peut plus travailler avec lui que
lorsqu'il s'est déclarée ni neyret c'est
vraiment au milieu sans jamais faire de
se réinventer lyonnais si l'union semble
bien avancer toujours pas d'annoncé
officielle
pour jean louis borloo les deux parties
ne sont toujours pas d'accord sur les
termes du contrat
en toile de fond d alliance modem ps aux
municipales notamment à dix jours le
diable se cache dans les détails
donc comme on n'est pas convoqué par la
police on attend de faire les choses
proprement
mais c'était mon objectif ya un an
j'avais dit je renierai tout le monde
voilà je pense que cet objectif et
réussit en ce qui concerne directement
lui dit et j'espère élargi
officiellement dans la chapelle
centriste personne n'est opposé à
l'union une conférence de presse commune
devrait réunie à jean louis borloo et
françois bayrou qui ne se sont pas
retrouvés sur la même photo de famille
depuis onze ans alors mariage de rêve au
mariage d'amour mariage absolument
nécessaire rassemblement absolument
nécessaire ou d'amour d'amitié mais
c'est pas simplement salle que deux ce
qui compte le plus c'est d'offrir une
alternative aux français c'est à dire de
d'être une offre nouvelle sur le champ
politique français on vient de parler de
l'état du pays on vienne parler de la
crise de confiance de la crise
d'autorité on pourrait rajouter que
quand on regarde un la désespérance des
français leur colère devant les
alternances successives depuis 30 ans
qui fait que à chaque fois on vous
raconte des blagues à chaque fois les
promesses ne sont jamais tenues etc
élection après élection on est deux
plus en plus déçus quand on regarde le
paysage politique qu'est ce qu'on
regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on voit au parti
socialiste on voit des divisions
idéologiques extrêmement lourdes et on
voit et on voit je le pense et on voit
et on voit attention et on voit l'ump
des tensions très fortes et bien à tout
cela nous répondons union nous répondons
rassemblement si on veut que le centre
soit fort dans le pays
si on veut qu'ils pèsent si on veut
qu'il soit entendu qu'il change le
paysage de la vie politique française
il faut qu'ils se rassemblent et c'est
ça que nous allons faire est ce que vous
avez déjà un texte commun avant un texte
commun lequel nous avons beaucoup
travaillé depuis quelques jours ou
quelques semaines et sur lequel jean
louis borloo et françois bayrou ont bien
travaillé puisque il est aujourd'hui
abouti et donc après ça va être une
question de dates deux jours dans les
jours qui vont venir jusqu'à dans les
jours qui vont venir vous nous verrez
vous verrez ensemble jean louis borloo
et françois my phone et leurs équipes
respectives pour le début d'une offre
nouvelle que nous allons proposer au
pays et c'est ça qui compte
ce qui va compter c'est pas simplement
de le faire ce rassemblement c'est qu'il
soit utile à la france et à l'europe
alors on a baladés notre micro dans les
coulisses de l'assemblée pour demander
aux parlementaires udi ce qu'il pensait
de ce mariage ils sont interrogés par
hugo leenhardt et rodolphe perron croit
que s'il a perdu quelques jours en tout
cas les choses sont bien engagées et son
vient d'engager puisque françois bayrou
a dit clairement qu'il était dans
l'opposition gouvernement dans une
opposition constructive comme nous le
sommes donc il s'agit de bâtir
naturellement un projet d'accord d'être
d'accord sur ce nombre de valeurs et
puis naturellement d'avoir des
partenaires privilégiés qu'ils sont
comme chacun sait l'ump la droite
républicaine en particulier la question
est posée le calendrier n'est pas encore
complètement arrêté puisqu'il ya une
discussion sur un contenu de charte qui
effectivement mettrait d'accord lui dit
et le modem
donc voilà donc il ya des discussions
qui se font comme dans tout contrat de
mariage
l'alliance entre jean louis borloo lui
dit et françois bayrou et le modem c'est
la reconstitution d'un axe central de la
vie politique et ça prend quelques temps
pour mettre en place les conditions de
cette alliance politique pourquoi est ce
que nous voulons un socle solide parce
que derrière nous voulons être crédibles
aux yeux des français
et vous savez quelquefois pour rédiger
un contrat de mariage dans un simple
couple il faut un peu de temps aux
notaires mais c'est le signe du sérieux
simplement je souhaite qu'il ait une
clarification politique on est dans
l'opposition plan national opposition
constructive une opposition ferme à des
choix qui nous conduisent droit dans le
mur
il faut qu'on clarifie la position plan
local peut pas être dans l'opposition
nationale et puis accepter l'idée qu'au
plan local le modèle puisse soutenir des
municipalités socialistes et participer
activement en tout le monde s'emballe
sur le d'accord en tout cas j'ai juste
entendu et l' opposition vous êtes
vraiment dans l'opposition ferme
écoutez on s'oppose au gouvernement et à
ses choix est assez non-choix j'allais
même et à son absence de choix pour
autant je suis contente que françois
sauvadet le disent bien sûr qu'il faut
que ce soit une opposition constructive
il faut que ce soit une opposition non
manichéenne on n'est pas là pour
rajouter banc n'est pas la foi dans la
caricature après c'est vous qui êtes
libre de vos jugements il y à des
personnalités à l'ump qui ont des
jugements nuancé moi je fais partie de
ceux qui ne se critique les choix qui
sont faits par le gouvernement mais qui
ont envie que mon pays réussissent je ne
souhaite pas l'échec de mon pays et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut une opposition
qui propose une opposition donc
intelligente pendant un petit peu c'est
voire peut-être un peu plus discordantes
peut-être qu'elles viennent aussi de
l'ump qui disent cet accord n'ira pas
bien loin c'est une alliance et
électoraliste pour les municipales et
surtout pour les européennes je
comprends que l'ump voilà se posent des
questions mais je pense qu'ils ont tort
parce que c'est absolument nécessaire
qu'il y ait dans ce pays un pluralisme
quand le centre existe et quand il est
fort qu'est ce qu'ils baissent ce sont
les extrêmes qui baisse et bien sûr ce
point là nous devrions les uns et les
autres ne semble-t-il nous rencontrer
sur le terrain des municipales quelle
sera la marge de manoeuvre politicienne
rond ensemble de ce que nous faisons
dans les villes mais vous savez dans la
plupart des 36000 communes on va dire ce
sont des faits locaux dans les toutes
les petites villes de france
les maires il faut qu autre chose ça
mais dans les petites villes de france
le maire on dit on des alliances locales
qui sont d'ailleurs en général non
partisane et ils ont bien raison
et puis dans les autres grandes villes
de france nous regarderons ensemble sur
marseille regardant syli a par exemple
une troisième voie possible est ce qu'il
peut y avoir une liste au centre à
marseille ou dans tous les cas une
équipe du centre qui se met au travail
et qui regarde ce qu'on peut apporter
dans cette élection municipale à paris
il faut que le centre s'affirme j'essaye
de faire en sorte qu'il le fasse je pose
nous posons à sa demande de propositions
et de contenus sur la table je souhaite
un renouvellement à bari je souhaite
qu'ils aient des rassemblements possible
aussi si je souhaite un renouvellement
ce que je considère que voilà
probablement il faut une équipe nouvelle
mais c'est pas simplement remplacer une
équipe ancien par une nouvelle équipe
qu'il faut c'est un changement je
voulais dit en profondeur dans la
manière de gouverner la ville
je note que la candidate de l'ump est
une candidate qui fait évoluer les
lignes au sein de son propre parti
politique
et je trouve ça intéressant juste un mot
de 2017 vous dites que le candidat futur
du centre sera choisi par une procédure
démocratique est ce que savait d'exo
même pour être exact la candidate ou le
candidat c'est une précision absolument
utile on va papa de confidences mais est
ce que ça implique du primaire est ce
que ça implique des primaires si on
avait voulu écrire primaire on aurait eu
mr nous disons le centre aura une
candidate ou un candidat et nous disons
cette candidate ou ce candidat sera
choisi par une procédure démocratique
possibilité mais ça laisse beaucoup de
possibilités salle nous laisse aussi la
possibilité d'innover dans ce domaine là
comme dans d'autres parce que il faut
que nous soyons une force de
propositions nouvelles on a besoin de
construire la france à 10 ans ou à 20
ans ce n'est pas une affaire d'élection
pour répondre sur la question des
élections
c'est une affaire de génération alors
parlons maintenant si vous le voulez
bien d'économies mardi les députés ont
voté ont voté une mesure importante
l'epargne sera davantage taxées ramener
le déficit de la sécu à 12,8 milliards
d'euros fin 2014
c'est le nouveau défi du gouvernement
les boissons énergisantes seront taxés
et la fiscalité augmente et pour
certains produits d'épargné et ce
rétroactivement mesure
inconstitutionnelle dit la droite mario
lefebvre
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour les 10
millions de détenteurs d'un plan
d'épargné logement
les cinq millions et demi de personnes
qui possèdent un plan d'epargne d'action
et tous ceux qui ont une assurance vie
désormais les plus values de tous ces
produits d'épargné seront taxés à 15,5
pour cette mesure que nous prenons est
une mesure d'équité car il n'est pas
normal que lorsque l'on détient des
actions directes et qu'on les vents ont
soit accès qu 1,5 et que ton compte
qu'on les tient dans le cadre d'un pea
on ne le soit pas le principe d'égalité
ça existe le principe d'équité
ça existe et le principe de
simplification de nos impôts ça existe
car ces plus values étaient taxés de
façon variable en fonction de l'année
d'ouverture du conte et de la date de
sortie des fonds à la tribune les
députés de l'opposition se sont succédé
pour dénoncer cette nouvelle hausse
d'impôt
la sécurité juridique et fiscal que vous
développez systématiquement avec des
mesures rétroactives sont
malheureusement tout à fait néfaste car
la taxation sera rétroactive et
s'appliquera depuis le 26 septembre
dernier
l'ump crie au scandale
estime que cette taxe est
anticonstitutionnelle le taux désormais
et dissuasif et sur toute cette
manoeuvre est rétroactive c'est tout à
fait inacceptable scandaleux c'est une
perte de confiance et qui risquent de se
manifester
au total cette uniformisation par le
haut des prélèvements sociaux devraient
rapporter 600 millions d'euros dans les
caisses de l'assurance maladie
1 l de sarnez est ce que pour vous il
est juste de taxer rétroactivement
certains produits aussi populaires que
le pel ou là sur non pas du tout bernard
acoyer sur ce point a absolument raison
ce dont on souffre en france ce dont nos
entreprises souffre
or c'est elles qui créent l'emploi c'est
pas l'état qui créent les emplois sont
les entreprises c'est d'une instabilité
total juridiques financières fiscales et
bien ceci ne peut plus durer
et là c'est exactement la même chose qui
se passe avec les parcs
quand vous n'êtes pas sûr quand vous
n'avez pas un cadre vous n'investissez
plus et donc il ya plus des pagnes à
plus d'investissements et évidemment
tout ceci va fragiliser plus encore
notre situation économique est déjà
catastrophique
donc je considère que c'est une mauvaise
mesure et moi je demande que françois
hollande
il repense à deux fois en particulier la
taxation de tous les pel de tous les
jeunes qui avaient avec des petits
salaires fait de toutes petites
économies sur le pays a réalisé et je
trouve que mais c'est le contraire de ce
qu'on voulait offrir à notre pays c'est
à dire un espoir pour notre jeunesse et
je demande que françois l'homme revienne
sur sa décision et le fait que ce soit
rétroactif ça vous choque également et
c'est très choquant c'est ça m'en voulez
vous gagner la confiance ou stabiliser
une confiance si vous vous dites ah bah
non seulement les règles vont changer
pour demain mais elles vont changer pour
hier c'est impossible et pourtant des
600 millions d'euros d'économies ou de
450 pour
pour notamment pour la sécurité sociale
ça va d'un bon sentiment
non je ne voit pas d'un bon sens c'est
un bon sentiment il ya un moment où on
ne peut plus au four stabiliser nos
dépenses ou faire baisser notre dépense
publique sans faire des réformes et sans
conduire des réformes sérieuses en trois
ans le temps de les conduire
on ne réglera pas les problèmes de la
france simplement par des impôts
supplémentaires des taxes
supplémentaires et qui plus est
justement un inventaire rétroactif
on réglera à l'aide de prélèvements ces
pros règlera les problèmes on règlera
les problèmes de la france
en prenant un par un les grandes
questions de la réforme par exemple de
l'état de la réforme par exemple des
collectivités locales et en allant
jusqu'au bout de réforme pour faire
mieux en dépensant un peu moins d'argent
pour vous la france donne le mauvais
exemple en europe en étant le deuxième
meilleur taux 46 % du produit intérieur
brut c'est ce que représentent les bien
sûr on a en a la dépense dernier que la
plus la plus haute d'europe et on ne
peut pas dire qu'on est le meilleur
système de protection d'europe donc il
ya quelque chose là qui ne va pas et
dont se sont par des réformes profondes
qu'on doit passer et pas par de la
simple taxation vous propose de passer
mercredi on va parler du droit du sol
on en parlait au début de cette émission
après laffaire leonarda c'est le débat
sur l'immigration qui est relancé le
gouvernement veut réformer le droit
d'asile l'ump répond réforme du droit du
sol les coutures ce reportage d'alain
gavand moudre
à la sortie du conseil des ministres
même ubs vient expliquer en personne sa
réforme du droit dette
nous avons lancé une concertation depuis
l'été dernier pour notamment comme l'a
rappelé le président de la république
samedi dernier c'était un engagement de
sa campagne accélérer les délais de
gestion du droit d'asile qui est un
droit peut vous le savez constitutionnel
le gouvernement veut à tout prix éviter
d'autres affaires leonarda la jeune
fille et sa famille ont résidé
illégalement quatre ans en france après
leur première demande d'asile
on ne peut plus accepter que comme on
l'a vu à l'occasion de cette affaire des
familles puissent rester sur le
territoire pendant quatre ans de recours
en recours à n'être pas fixé sur leur
propre sort la mission parlementaire
livrera ses conclusions mi novembre avec
deux objectifs raccourcir les délais de
gestion de chaque dossier en moyenne un
demandeur d'asile attend une décision un
an et demi et limiter les recours
possibles après un refus
si la gauche s'occupe donc du droit
d'asile la droite elle entend s'attaquer
au droit du sol qui permet aux enfants
d'étrangers d'obtenir automatiquement la
nationalité française à leur majorité
s'ils ont résidé un nombre d'années
minimum en france
il s'agit simplement de dire que des
parents des enfants nés en france de
parents illégalement installés sur le
territoire français ne peuvent pas
devenir automatiquement français c'est
incompréhensible
après une réflexion en interne
l'opposition pourrait déposer une
proposition loi plus globale sur
l'immigration voilà le clivage politique
qui reprend de conception de philosophie
droit d'asile droit du sol le droit du
sol c'est une philosophie fondamentale
du pacte républicain et les ja je vois
que à l'ump nombre de responsables et de
personnalités politiques l'ont exprimée
récemment
et puis il faut que nous sachions entre
nous que nous avons un droit du sol qui
est relatif c'est à dire qu'on ne
devient pas français par la naissance on
devient français par le droit du sol en
étant resté un certain nombre d'années
sur le territoire en étant assia sa
tombe d'années cette étoffe pense qu'il
est important de dire les choses c'est
très important
qui veut revenir manger seul vous êtes
d'accord je crois qu'il faut répondre
poser les bonnes questions et essayer
d'y répondre
la bonne question c'est comment on règle
comme en maîtrise la question de
l'immigration illégale et je pense que
la voie choisie par manuel valls et la
bonne c'était d'ailleurs ce que jacques
chirac disait il ya une vingtaine
d'années là où on a des abus ce sont
dans les demandes de droit d'asile
puisqu'on a à peu près simplement 10% de
ces demandes qui sont regardés
favorablement qui ont des réponses
positives par an ce qui veut dire qu'il
y a trente mille personnes à qui nous
faisons des réponses négatives
et bien moi je demande une chose c'est
qu'on n'attende pas trois ans quatre ans
cinq ans pour dire à ces familles que
leur demande de droit d'asile politique
est rejetée je trouve que jean françois
copé
on va enfants va pas personnaliser je
considère non mais je considère que
vouloir à tout prix reprendre les mêmes
mots que le front national c'est pas la
façon de le faire baisser
la manière de faire baisser le front
national c'est d'être nous-mêmes d'avoir
une cohérence d'avoir des convictions
d'avoir nos propres valeurs et au nom de
ces valeurs là d'apporter des réponses
aux problèmes le problème c'est un
l'immigration illégale
donc oui réformons le droit d'asile
d'ailleurs c'est une parlementaire
centriste en particulier valérie l'état
pour laquelle j'ai beaucoup d'estimé qui
va notamment remettre un rapport à
manuel valls qui va je le sais aller
dans le très bon sens deuxièmement je
considère que nous devons réfléchir à la
manière de penser les flux migratoires
de demain pour les réguler et qu'on doit
le faire au plan européen et pas
simplement au plan franco français voilà
deux propositions que je fais sur la
table pour vous marielle de sarnez c'est
le bon moment pour lancer ces réformes
il faut aussi qu'elle soit fait en
coordination avec l'agenda européen mais
il faut qu'elle soit fait en
coordination avec l'agenda européen
parce que nous avons une question de
flux migratoires qui concerne l'ensemble
des pays de l'union européenne j'ajoute
que je suis depuis longtemps j'ajoute
que je suis aussi depuis longtemps pour
que nous ayons un partenariat nouveau
afrique union européenne que l'afrique
est demandeuse qu'on ne regarde pas
assez au fond quelles sont les
valorisations les potentiels de
croissance de ce grand continent
oui ça peut être une opportunité
formidable pour autant qu'on la
saisissent alors question d'actualité
justement 100% européenne
ce mercredi dans l'hémicycle les députés
ont notamment interpellé le gouvernement
sur la politique migratoire de l'europe
on en parle et aussi sur l'entrée plus
spécifiquement de la roumanie et de la
bulgarie dans schengen je vous demande
solennellement comme nous l'avons fait
par le passé d'opposer un veto à
l'entrée de la bulgarie et de la
roumanie dans l'espace schengen au 1er
janvier 2014
pour ce qui concerne schengen et vous
l'avez dit mais il faut le dire encore
plus clairement ce n'est pas une
question qui concerne l'union européenne
en son sein mais évidemment
l'organisation et la surveillance des
frontières extérieures
il n'est d'ailleurs pas de décision
concernant le 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine le 1er janvier 2014
faut pas confondre ce sujet là avec la
problématique de l'ouverture au travail
mais il s'agit tout simplement de dire
qu'aujourd'hui le ministre des affaires
étrangères a déjà eu l'occasion de le
souligner la bulgarie et la roumanie ne
sont pas prêts pour entrer dans schengen
et le gouvernement la france a déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire
alors il ya beaucoup de confusion autour
de ce sujet encore ministre clarifier un
peu vous même en tant que députée
européenne qu'elle est votre conviction
et la france a raison de refuser
l'entrée raison de refuser l'accès à
l'espace schengen de la roumanie et de
la bulgarie parce que quand on est dans
l'espace schengen les pays qui en sont
membres doivent assurer assumer la
surveillance des frontières extérieures
de l'union européenne avec d'autres pays
schengen c'est sa salle et que ça et ça
résonne d'une invitation nation pas du
tout on mélange deux choses roumanie et
bulgarie ne doivent pas entrer ils ne
sont pas aujourd'hui en capacité tout le
monde le sait de surveiller efficacement
leurs frontières extérieures schengen
sur la gîte le chiffon rouge à quelques
questions
regardez ce qui se passe à malte ou à
lampedusa
là aussi c'est le problème de la
surveillance de la méditerranée et des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne et en particulier de l'espace
de schengen schengen fonctionnera quand
on mettra aussi un certain nombre de
moyens en place moi je suis pour faire
une proposition pour mettre un certain
nombre de mettre en place des garde
côtes européen
comme il ya d'ailleurs aux états unis je
fais cette proposition depuis longtemps
c'est vraiment uniquement une question
de volonté politique des chefs d'état
gouvernement dans l'union européenne où
il faut vous dire concrètement faisons
de pause
approfondissons d'abord notre union
européenne réformes ont ce qu'ils
méritent d'être réformée avant d'élargir
la turquie non nous la turquie non et
d'autres pays non je vous dis faisons
une pause
approfondissons l'union européenne c'est
un enjeu absolument énorme
on doit recréer la confiance entre les
citoyens de l'union européenne et le
fonctionnement de l'europe et donc oui
il faut porter à sa tombe de réforme et
c'est aux européens que nous sommes de
porter ces réformes
allez hop à ce que je dis on va parler
logement au sénat et en plein débat
parlementaire sur la loi duflot une des
mesures phares l'encadrement des loyers
a été vivement critiqué par le conseil
d'analysé économique c'est un organisme
très proche du gouvernement l'article a
pourtant été votée la veille de la
sortie de ce rapport il est jugé
inopérant inefficace rapport qui remet
en cause également les aides au logement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez marielle de
sarnez vous qui avez présenté cette
semaine votre plan marshall pour le
logement
c'est à dire la production de 100 mille
logements supplémentaires l'innovation
avec des baux emphytéotiques la
couverture des gares pour la création de
vingt mille nouveaux logements
construits et ump ont dit du bien est
donc temps voyez c'est le conseil
d'analysé économique qui a raison il
faut mettre de côté les deux
propositions qui sont un l'encadrement
de la garantie universelle locative
parce qu'on va arriver à quelque chose
de très simple avec la loi duflot ce
qu'ils sont on va dire les plus pauvres
pour aller vite ceux qui sont les moins
aisés vont voir leurs loyers augmenter
ceux qui sont les plus aisés vont voir
leurs loyers diminuer alors écoutez on
rêve complètement bien évidemment il
faut qu'on remette et que le
gouvernement remette renouvelle cholet
sonata proposés
cette mesure je propose à la place
d'avoir des observatoires comme ça se
fait partout comme ça se fait en
allemagne comme ça se fait au québec
d'avoir des observatoires des prix du
loyer avec siégeant des gens qui sont
bailleurs propriétaires et que
l'observatoire rendre publics les prix
on va lire quartier par quartier pâté de
maison par pâté de maison et qu'on
renvoie quand il ya un problème qu'on
renvoie non pas immédiatement la justice
qui est déjà complètement embouteillée
mais qu'on renvoie à une gestion
prud'homale ou en tous les cas à des
médiateurs
je pense que là la france pourrait
innover en s'inspirant utilement de ce
que font nos voisins je veux vous
entendre sur un portrait précis cette
semaine qui a vu au sénat en commission
des affaires économiques le projet de
loi sur les retraites a été retoqué
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous je
comprends qu'il était en toc et jaugeant
regrette que le gouvernement n'ait pas
pris n'est pas apporter davantage de
considération à la proposition que le
groupe du centre a fait au sénat et en
particulier celle qui a été porté par
jean marie vanlerenberghe qui reprenait
ce que nous disons et françois bayrou
depuis longtemps c'est à dire qu'on a
besoin d'une vraie réforme de fond des
retraites
avec enfin la mise en place d'un système
par points et à terme et à terme un
régime unique chacun de ceux qui ayant
été dans les régimes spéciaux gardant
évidemment leurs avantages acquis et
donc là aussi le gouvernement a loupé
une occasion ça peut marcher en france
là là mais ça ne marchera forcément ça
se fera un jour parce que pour rendre
pour pérenniser notre système de
retraite est pour avoir un système de
retraites juste et pas tout faire
reposer sur les futures générations
c'est la seule solution tous les pays
d'europe au fond qui ont réfléchi à
cette question la mise en oeuvre ça
prend du temps être mises en oeuvre et
c'est pour ça que je regrette vraiment
françois hollande ne l'est pas décider
parce que ça prend non ça prend du temps
parce que c'est long à mettre en oeuvre
donc ça prend 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans et donc
on devrait d'autant plus l'organiser et
le lancer dès aujourd'hui je propose de
faire partie de notre émission c'est le
plus de l'hebdo à s'intéresser aux
lanceurs d'alert ces nouveaux héros du
nouveau monde
c'est le cinquième pouvoir wikileaks et
ses révélations ont fait l'effet d'une
bombe un film vient de sortir aux états
unis
il raconte l'histoire de l'organisation
et de son fondateur julian assange
la sortie est prévue en france le 4
décembre
un film qui fait déjà du bruit sur fond
d'affaires d' écoutes américaines si
longue barbarie après avoir fait
trembler l'administration américaine les
lanceurs d'alertés font tousser
hollywood de long métrage le cinquième
pouvoir consacré au fondateur de
wikileaks julian assange est un échec au
box office
enfin m
un flop en partie attribuée aux plus
célèbres cybermilitants de la planète
julian assange lui même une arme de
propagande massive au service des états
unis selon lui pourtant ce film se veut
une illustration fidèles de la
trajectoire de wikileaks entre 2007 et
2010 période où l'organisation révèle
des abus commis par l'armée américaine
en irak et en afghanistan et pour
concilier ce que l'on a nommé le cabl
get rich un diplomate
le cinquième pouvoir dans les salles
françaises le 4 décembre prochain
soulève une question cruciale
les lanceurs d'alertés sont ils de
dangereux traître une des héros
visionnaire à l'heure où les révélations
de l'ancien agent de la nsa edouard
snowdon continue de jeter le trouble
dans les relations diplomatiques
américaines des lanceurs d'alerté
à défaut d'avoir un rôle majeur à
hollywood sont déjà des acteurs
puissants dans le cercle très fermé des
relations internationales et sa famille
sont nombreux
marielle de sarnez pour reprendre la
question du réalisateur bill comme
d'années ce que les lanceurs dallaire
que les whistleblowers comme julian à
saint jo edwards snowdon sont des héros
des temps modernes de nouveaux héros oui
oui genre t'as des héros j'utiliserai
peut-être pas ce mot là mais non mais
c'est très important et c'est très
intéressant en même temps et je
considère que les citoyens du monde
ils ont le droit à avoir un certain
nombre à dax et un certain nombre
d'informations à regarder ce qui se
passe avec les écoutes téléphoniques et
se passe en europe vous allez venir
mais si snow day n'était pas là est-ce
que ce sujet serait sur la table
en aucun cas alors je suis pas naïve je
suppose que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement européens connaissait déjà
un certain nombre de méthodes des
américains et qu'au fond il s'en
accommoder et bien si ces temps-là
change si l'opinion publique ce est
saisie de cela par les lanceurs d'alerté
et dis-moi opinion publique française ou
européenne
je ne m'accommode pas que les américains
que j'aime par ailleurs j'aime les
américains mais que les américains
viennent chez moi comme s'il était le
gendarme du monde ou de l'europe
eh bien peut-être les choses changeront
un peu tout le monde écoute tout le
monde qu'est-ce qui lui enfin écoutez
j'ai vu l'ancien chef des services
secrets français qui a dit ça à mon avis
la france soit disant écoute les états
unis je pense qu'alain qui écoute un peu
plus que l'autre
on veut tourner en rond avec ça de moi
tout simplement le débat est lancé je
trouve c'est un bon débat et moi je dis
ce sont pas des explications qu'on doit
demander aux américains
on doit mettre fin à cette situation
comment ça n'est pas pareil quand et
j'espère que le conseil européen va
avancer dans ce sens puisque angela
merkel était elle-même plus confortable
et côté nord mais peut-être qu'elle est
au téléphone au parlement pour vous ce
genre de situation et ça n'est pas
tenable d'ailleurs je ne sais pas en
trouver moi ce qu'ils font de toutes ces
millions de données qu'est ce que ça
leur apporte
problème on flingue l'exploitation de
ces prêts quand même dans une vie
politique assez transparente
mais il ya un principe c'est le principe
de souveraineté et moi je crois à ça on
a une souveraineté française on a une
souveraineté européenne et donc ça n'est
pas aux américains de venir faire la
police ou
en dames chez nous le new york times
écrit cette semaine le taux sévère de la
france révèle plutôt du théâtre
politique plutôt qu'une réelle à bout
nation c'est normal tout ça c'est ils
sont tous acoquiné les uns les autres
moi en tous les cas j'ai une réelle
indignation je pense que les américains
ne peuvent pas se penser par tous
légitimes sur toute la planète
la question qui se pose c'est aussi
celle de la protection des données des
citoyens roumains c'est un dossier
central en europe et qui tarde à avancer
concrètement comment l'europe qu'est ce
que l'europe peut faire pour protéger
ses citoyens de l'intrusion de deux
géants d'internet comme google
il faut qu'elle se décide de le faire
déjà et que nos chefs d'état et de
gouvernement décide de le faire et
décide de peser dans particulier pour
l'art est expert des auberges et bien
évidemment les et ce dossier est sur la
table et il faut avancer
ouais je vous écoute pas remis de cette
émission avec une photo vous allez
découvrir tout de suite ségolène royal
est peut-être venu découvrir cette photo
pi lui sur un tapis rouge qui pose en
toque blanche drapeau français
étendard à la façon de la liberté et le
peuple célèbre tableau de delacroix
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé de cette
photo de ségolène royal où joue en
français les yeux non je ne pense pas
les yeux j'hésite entre l'amusement
l'étonnement mais c'est assez baroque
quand même au courage en politique ces
gens c'est peut-être courageuse qu'elle
a fait qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour
vous le courage aux politiques le
courage en politique ça vient pour moi
d'y à la vérité à nos concitoyens ne pas
leur raconter des bobards tenir ce que
l'on dit et continuer mordicus de
défendre ses convictions et j'ajouterai
un mot que pour moi la fin ne doit
jamais justifié les moyens en politique
qui a le courage en politique en ce
moment quelques courageux pense moi j'en
connais un bien qui est françois bayrou
pense que c'est un homme qui est très
courageux mais qui coûte et c'est
quelqu'un dont le parcours fait que on
se rend compte qu'à chaque fois qu'il
exprime quelque chose ou qu'il prend une
décision il le fait en conscience et pas
forcément pour son propre intérêt et
même plutôt l'inversé
et bien c'est un courage qui vaut pour
moi admiration ségolène royal dit
ce qui serait courageux appliqué
aujourd'hui c'est le non cumul des
mandats tout de suite et les fusions de
départements et régions françois bayrou
un référendum sur la moralisation de la
vie publique
et si vous me demandez si je regrette
que françois hollande n'avait pas fait
je vous dis oui je le regrette vivement
est ce qu'il est trop tard non il n'est
pas trop tard il faut moraliser notre
vie publique et les lois qui sont en
vigueur aujourd'hui ne sont pas allés
assez loin et françois hollande devrait
faire appel au référendum pour imposer
aux élus c'était la plupart d'entre eux
évidemment se refuse à eux mêmes le
courage en politique et ailleurs en
europe se serait illustré par qui pour
vous en quelle année retirer la rigole
franchement parce que je vais vous dire
pourquoi tout à l'heure on disait il
faut faire attention il faut pas courir
comme ça après le front national il faut
rester campé sur ses convictions faut
avoir de la cohérence
quand on a de la cohérence comme angela
merkel eh bien on devient un repère et
quand on est un repère on pèse et on
peut faire rayonner un certain nombre
d'idées et moi je regrette qu'il n'y ait
pas assez de cohérence dans la vie
politique française de cohérence au
gouvernement de cohérence chez le chef
de l'état c'est comme ça que l'on peut
être forcée en cohérence le courage ou
la semaine françois bayrou angela merkel
oui absolument
merci beaucoup moins de 16 ans participe
à notre émission bonne semaine katia on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine dans
nos bacs de semaine très bonne suite du
programme sur les chaînes parlementaires
et merci de votre fidélité
pour c